[Musique]
madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés
en m'adressant à vous c'est à la france
que je parle
chacune de vos circonscriptions
porte une parcelle de notre histoire et
des défis qui s'ouvre devant nous
chacun de vos territoires
exprime une réalité de notre pays
de ces craintes un et de ses espoirs
nous mesurons tous l'ampleur de la tâche
les français à protéger la république à
défendre notre pays a rassemblé la
planète à préserver
c'est le sens de l'action du président
de la république depuis cinq ans c'est
notre mission collective au gouvernement
comme sur ces bancs
avec vous avec tout le gouvernement avec
nos concitoyens nous réussirons j'y suis
déterminé
ces dernières semaines à quatre reprises
les françaises et les français se sont
exprimés
par le résultat des urnes
ils nous demandent d'agir et d'agir
autrement
par leur message ils nous demandent de
prendre collectivement nos
responsabilités nous le ferons
ensemble nous répondrons à l'écho de
l'abstention elle est le signe d'une
démocratie malade d'un désarroi de la
jeunesse d'une perte de confiance dans
notre capacité à changer les vies
ensemble nous répondrons à la demande
d'actions c'est celle qui s'exprime le
plus fortement dans le vote des français
nous ne pouvons pas décevoir
ensemble nous répondrons à l'exigence de
responsabilité
les français ont élu une assemblée sans
majorité absolue il nous invite à des
pratiques nouvelles un dialogue soutenu
à la recherche active de compromis
le contexte nous oblige la guerre en
ukraine aux portes de l'europe nous
rappelle combien la paix est fragile
les prix de l'énergie augmentent et nous
devons continuer à protéger des français
l'épidémie est toujours là et notre
vigilance doit rester total
l'urgence écologique se fait chaque
seconde plus pressante et nous avons un
devoir d'action
l'insécurité inquiète nos concitoyens et
brise encore des vies et des destins
nous devons le dire aussi dans les
dernières semaines du fait de la guerre
qui dure notre situation économique
s'est assombri nos perspectives de
croissance se dégradent les taux
d'intérêt augmentent quant à nos
finances publiques elles doivent
reprendre le chemin de l'équilibré
face à de tels défis le désordre et
l'instabilité ne sont pas des options
nous ne sommes peut-être pas d'accord
sur toutes les solutions mais nous avons
toutes et tous conscience de l'urgence
et de la nécessité d'agir
les français nous demandent de nous
parler plus de nous parler mieux est de
construire ensemble
nous répondrons
nous répondrons présent je veux qu'on
semble nous redonnions un sens et une
vertus au mot compromis depuis trop
longtemps oubliées dans notre vie
politique
le compromis ce n'est pas se
compromettre ces taxes accepté chacun de
faire un pas vers l'autre cela ne
signifie nullement l'effacement de nos
différences ou le renoncement à nos
convictions les clivages existent et ils
continueront à exister bâtir ensemble ne
signifie pas renoncer à son identité
la mienne vous le savez a pour socle
inaltérable les valeurs de notre
république la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité la laïcité
mon identité c'est une france plus forte
dans une europe plus indépendante c'est
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
toujours tout le temps c'est le respect
de la laïcité sans un commandement dit
compromission c'est le refus d'opposer
les uns aux autres et de désigner des
boucs émissaires c'est le courage de
dire la vérité aux français
c'est forte de ses convictions des
valeurs que je chéris et protège comme
femme comme citoyenne comme élu comme
premier ministre que je crois
souhaitable et possible que chaque
conviction chaque idée puisse être
défendus débattu et s'il le faut
combattu trop longtemps notre vie
politique n'a été faite que deux blocs
qui s'affrontent
il est temps d'entrer dans l'ère des
forces qui bâtissent ensemble
une majorité relative n'est pas et ne
sera pas le synonyme d'une action
relative
elle n'est pas
elle n'est pas et ne sera pas de signe
de l'impuissance
rappelons nous qu'en 1958 les gaullistes
les gaullistes ne sont pas majoritaires
à l'assemblée nationale quand la vème
république connaît ses premières armes
et crée les chu et l'assurance chômage
rappelons nous que c'est le gouvernement
rocard qui n'avait pourtant qu'une
majorité relative sur ses bancs qui a
créé le rmi la csg et lancer le
processus de paix en nouvelle calédonie
nous avons encore des droits à conquérir
des progrès à réaliser des protections à
bâtir s'ils y sont parvenus nous y
parviendrons
ces dernières semaines le président de
la république garant de nos actes de nos
institutions et moi même avons consulté
écoutez nous avons proposé plusieurs
manières de faire pour l'urgence comme
pour les années à venir
le résultat de nos échanges est clair
une nouvelle page de notre histoire
politique et parlementaire commence
celle des majorités de projet
avec mon gouvernement
j'en serai l'infatigable bâtisseuse
je sais combien nous sommes attendus et
je ne suis pas femme à me dérober ni
devant les défis ni devant les débats
je ne corresponds peut-être pas au
portrait robot que certains attendaient
cela tombe bien la situation est inédite
je n'ai pas le complexe de la femme
providentielle j'ai été ingénieur femme
d'entreprise préfète ministre mon
parcours on a suivi qu'un fil rouge
servir
je ne suis pas une femme de grandes
phrases et de petits mots je suis
convaincu que ses habitudes ont nourri
les postures la défiance et la crise de
notre démocratie
pour ma part je crois en trois choses
l'écoutent l'action et les résultats je
n'ai qu'une boussole ici
je n'ai qu'une boussole qui sera celle
de mon gouvernement
bâtir pour notre pays
alors mon gouvernement ne sera jamais
celui des clivages factice et des idées
toutes faites car je crois fermement au
dépassement entamé il ya cinq ans par le
président de la république
je suis fier d'avoir servi dans les
gouvernements de premier ministre qui
n'avait pas la même histoire politique
que moi fier de mener aujourd'hui une
équipe diverse ou les parcours et les
expériences se complètent et se
renforcent
fier est impatiente de commencer avec
vous un travail de fond et d'idées
projet par projet au service des
français
nous mènerons pour chaque sujet une
concertation danse nous aborderons
chaque texte dans un esprit de dialogue
et de compromis et d'ouverture nous
inscrirons dans le cadre et les valeurs
portées par le projet du président de la
république
je les dis au président de groupe de
cette assemblée nous sommes prêts à
entendre les propositions venues de
chacun à en débattre et si nous
partageons les objectifs et les valeurs
à amender notre projet cette méthode de
travail nous devrons l'incarner pour
réfléchir collectivement à l'avenir et
aux évolutions de nos institutions sous
l'égide du président de la république
une commission de transport qu'ils anne
sera lancé à la rentrée pour y parvenir
cette méthode nous devrons la porter au
delà des murs de cette assemblée nous
associerons davantage des élus locaux à
nos réflexions et nos décisions ils sont
le ciment de notre république nous
devons laisser des marges de manoeuvre
aux territoires car c'est dans les
solutions différenciées que se trouvent
les résultats concrets et la vraie
égalité
je ne crois pas que notre école notre
santé connaissent les mêmes défis dans
le centre de paris dans les quartiers de
cayenne dans un village au bord de la
vire nous consulterons plus encore les
corps intermédiaires des forces vives de
notre pays les françaises et les
français dans chaque territoire
plus que jamais nous mènerons chaque
réforme en lien étroit avec les
organisations syndicales et patronales
nous avons besoin d'elles et elles
savent qu'elles trouveront en moi une
interloqué une interlocutrice franches
constructives et déterminé
associer toutes les forces vives du pays
dans un dialogue renouvelé et en
partageant les opportunités comme les
contraintes c'est le sens du conseil
national de la refondation voulue par le
président de la république
les français nous attendent
ils accepteront ni immobilisme ni
obstruction ni invectives ils veulent un
gouvernement et un parlement d'action
nous avons une responsabilité historique
vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens
responsabilité dans la manière d'agir
dans les réponses à offrir dans les
résultats à porter
alors à partir du cadre qu'ont choisi
les français je vous propose de bâtir
ensemble
notre premier défi et je sais que cela
fait consensus parmi nous c'est de
répondre à l'urgence du pouvoir d'achat
sous l'impulsion du président de la
république
de nombreuses mesures ont été prises
depuis l'automne dernier pour protéger
les français de l'augmentation des prix
sans elle les prix de l'électricité
aurait augmenté d'un tiers grâce à elle
la hausse a été limitée à 4%
sans elle les prix du gaz devraient
augmenter de 45% grâce à elle les prix
ont été bloqués
sans elle un plein de 60 litres
coûterait 11 euros de plus nous avons
réalisé un investissement rapide et
massif pour le pouvoir d'achat des
français grâce à lui notre inflation est
la plus faible de la zone euro nous
avons protégé les français nous allons
continuer car beaucoup de nos
concitoyens reste à la merci de chaque
hausse de prix dès demain mon
gouvernement présentera en conseil des
ministres des textes d'urgence face à
l'inflation ils comporteront des mesures
concrètes rapides et efficaces nous vous
proposerons de prolonger le bouclier
tarifaires sur les prix du gaz et de
l'électricité
d'augmenter les revenus du travail et de
mieux partager la valeur en baissant les
charges sur les indépendants et en
triplant le plafond de la prime de
pouvoir d'achat de revaloriser les
retraites et les prestations sociales
notamment les allocations familiales la
prime d'activité les apl l'allocation
adulte handicapé de revaloriser les
bourses sur critères sociaux d'aider les
travailleurs pour lesquels la voiture
est une nécessité
ces mesures sont notre base de travail
avec mon gouvernement nous serons à
votre écoute et nous les amendes rond
quand des convergences émergeront
au-delà de l'urgence pour la plupart des
français le logement et la première
dépense nous voulons qu'ils soient
abordables pour chacun nous avons décidé
d'un plafonnement de la hausse des
loyers et nous proposeront de nouvelles
solutions pour que le logement soit
accessible partout en ouvrant la caution
publique aux classes moyennes en
construisant davantage de logements dans
les zones en tension en concluant un
pacte de confiance avec les acteurs du
logement social en proposant
collectivités un nouvel acte de
décentralisation pour concentrer les
moyens et les responsabilités à
l'échelle des bassins de vie tout en
étant exigeant pour qu'elle permette au
projet de sortir de terre le pouvoir
d'achat c'est aussi la garantir à tous
l'accès à une alimentation saine et de
qualité nous définirons avec les
professionnels avec les associations
avec vous les contours du chèque
alimentation
le pouvoir d'achat c'est venir en aide
aux plus vulnérables
nous voulons que chacun perçoivent les
aides auxquelles il a droit avec la
solidarité à la source mettront fin à
l'injustice sociale du non recours et
nous lutterons plus efficacement contre
la fraude
mais je veux l'affirmé les deux clés du
pouvoir d'achat durable c'est le plein
emploi c'est la transition écologique
j'y reviendrai sur tous ces sujets je
suis convaincu que nous pouvons trouver
des solutions communes mais nous devrons
garder en tête trois principes la
responsabilité environnementale d'abord
nous devons prendre en compte l'impact
environnemental de toutes nos mesures et
remplacé dès que possible nous dépenses
en faveur des énergies fossiles par des
solutions décarbonés la responsabilité
budgétaire ensuite les mesure massives
que nous avons mises en oeuvre ont
protégé les français il fallait les
prendre mais aujourd'hui nous devons
retrouver des perspectives claires pour
l'amélioration de nos comptes publics
c'est une nécessité pour continuer à
financer notre modèle social c'est un
devoir vis-à-vis des générations futures
une déclaration de politique générale
c'est un moment de vérité
un moment de partage aussi des
contraintes des contraintes auxquelles
nous faisons face
les données sont claires du fait de la
guerre qui dure et comme partout en
europe notre croissance économique sera
plus faible que prévu l'inflation sera
plus forte et la charge de la dette
augmente nos objectifs sont eux aussi
clair en 2026 nous devons commencer à
baisser la dette en 2027 nous devrons
ramener le déficit sous les 3%
ces objectifs nous les atteindrons en
bâtissant les conditions d'une
croissance forte et durable qui créera
les emplois en menant les réformes
nécessaires en prenant des mesures de
bonne gestion et en accentuant la lutte
contre les fraudes
l'équilibré de nos finances publiques
est une question de souveraineté je sais
que beaucoup y sont attachées sur ses
bancs nous en avons parlé justement
monsieur le président marc l'ex
enfin notre troisième principe c'est le
respect ferme de l'engagement pris par
le président de la république devant les
français
c'est le respect de l'engagement pris
par le président de la république devant
les français pas beau il vous plait mes
chers collègues
nous devons cesser 2 nous devons cesser
de croire qu'à chaque défi la solution
est une taxe alors pas de hausse d'impôt
nous sommes crédibles nous avons
supprimé la dac la taxe d'habitation et
baisser l'impôt sur le revenu au total
nous avons diminué les impôts des
français ou des entreprises de plus de
50 milliards pendant le précédent
quinquennat
dès cet été nous tiendrons parole la
suppression de la redevance
audiovisuelle permettra de faire
économiser 138 euros à plus de 20
millions de feuilles de
l ira de pair avec une réforme du
financement de l'audiovisuel public qui
garantira son indépendance et des moyens
pérennes nous y travaillerons ensemble
la fiscalité sera un de nos terrains de
débat mais elle peut aussi être un sujet
de consensus entre nous nous en parlions
monsieur le président mattei
j'ajoute que le pouvoir d'achat est un
combat collectif
chacun doit y prendre sa part et
notamment les entreprises qui dégagent
des marges au moment où l'inflation est
forte j'attends des employeurs qui le
peuvent qu'ils prennent leurs
responsabilités
nous pouvons nous devons aller plus loin
en la matière
notre deuxième défi c'est de bâtir
ensemble la société du plein emploi
c'est une conviction qui m'anime
profondément une conviction nourri par
mon parcours par deux ans comme ministre
du travail par nos échanges et parce que
j'ai avec nos concitoyens
nous devons changer notre rapport au
travail et le coeur de ce changement
c'est le plein emploi et le bon emploi
ce n'est pas une illusion ça n'est pas
un objectif inatteignable
aujourd'hui le plein emploi est à notre
portée et le travail reste pour moi un
levier heures d'émancipation
lors du précédent quinquennat nous avons
déjà parcouru la moitié du chemin vers
le plein emploi nous avons le taux de
chômage le plus bas depuis 15 ans le
taux de chômage des jeunes le plus bas
depuis 40 ans la part des français qui
ont un travail qui n'a jamais été aussi
élevé depuis que la mesure
c'est le résultat des réformes de fond
que nous avons menée pendant cinq ans
nous avons déverrouiller l'apprentissage
avec plus de 700000 apprentis en 2021
nous avons rendu le travail toujours
plus incitatif avec la réforme de
l'assurance chômage nous avons amélioré
et intensifier la formation des
demandeurs d'emplois en investissant 15
milliards d'euros dans la formation
professionnelle
nous avons mieux accompagner les jeunes
grâce au plan un jeune une solution et
aux contrats d'engagement jeunes
c'est grâce à ce bilan que nous pouvons
désormais viser le plein emploi j'ai la
conviction profonde que notre pays doit
et peut sortir du cercle vicieux du
chômage de masse
aujourd'hui la situation de l'emploi a
changé dans notre pays de nombreuses
entreprises dans toutes les filières
dans tous les métiers et dans tous les
territoires cherche à recruter cette
situation a des vertus elle impose aux
employeurs d'améliorer les conditions de
travail de questionner leur mode de
management et d'oeuvrer à l'attractivité
de leur métier avec le plein emploi les
travailleurs retrouvent le pouvoir de
négocier et pour atteindre le plein
emploi nous devrons aussi ramener vers
l'emploi celles et ceux qui sont le plus
éloignés du marché du travail je pense
aux jeunes bien sûr que nous
continuerons à accompagner mais je pense
aussi aux bénéficiaires du rsa ce que
nous voulons c'est leur permettre de
retrouver un travail
comme le disait michel rocard ne perdons
pas la volonté tenace de l'insertion
revenons à l'esprit du rmi et du rsa
verser une allocation ne suffit pas ce
que nous voulons c'est que chacun s'en
sortent et retrouve sa dignité par le
travail
ce que nous proposons c'est ni plus ni
moins qu'une mesure de justice sociale
d'équilibré entre les droits et des
devoirs
[Applaudissements]
le plein emploi nous l'atteindrons aussi
en accompagnant mieux les chômeurs
aujourd'hui notre organisation est trop
complexe son efficacité en pâtit nous ne
pouvons plus continuer à avoir d'un côté
l'état qui accompagne les demandeurs
d'emploi de l'autre les régions qui
s'occupent de leur formation et les
départements en charge de l'insertion
des bénéficiaires du rsa
c'est pour cela que nous voulons
transformer pôle emploi en france
travaillent
[Applaudissements]
nous devons joindre nos forces
travailler ensemble pour être plus
efficace dans l'accompagnement des
chômeurs c'est comme ça que chaque
français trouvera sa place dans le
marché du travail et que nous répondrons
aux besoins de recrutement des
entreprises
le plein emploi c'est aussi relever le
défi de la découverte des métiers de
l'orientation et de la formation
cela commence dès l'enseignement
secondaire
avec les régions nous ferons en sorte
que chaque élève puisse découvrir et
connaître des métiers notamment ceux de
l'artisanat de l'industrie du tourisme
les métiers d'art nous élargirons au
lycée professionnel le succès de
l'apprentissage ils se défient ne
s'arrête pas à la fin du lycée nous
devrons dans le supérieur permettre que
les étudiants choisissent et se lance
dans une voie en fonction du métier
qu'ils veulent exercer
mais grâce à la formation tout au long
de la vie qu'ils puissent se sentir
libres d'en changer et de saisir de
nouvelles opportunités
grâce à cela ces prochaines années nous
pourrons former un million de jeunes
dans les métiers d'avenir dont la moitié
dans le numérique
enfin c'est grâce au plein emploi que
nous créerons de la richesse et que nous
pourrons financer notre modèle social
vous le savez nous avons toujours dit
les choses clairement aux françaises et
aux français
[Applaudissements]
en la matière
en la matière la transparence est une
exigence des faux semblants un manque de
respect pour nos concitoyens
notre modèle social est un paradoxe à la
fois l'un des plus généreux est l'un de
ceux où l'on travaille le moins
longtemps notre système de retraite est
une exception alors que l'on part plus
tard chez la totalité de nos voisins
européens
alors je le dis aujourd'hui pour la
prospérité de notre pays et la pérennité
de notre système par répartition pour
bâtir de nouveaux progrès sociaux pour
coca retraités avec une carrière
complète mais une pension inférieure à
1100 euros par mois pour sortir de
situations où le même métier ne garantit
pas la même retraite oui nous devrons
travailler progressivement un peu plus
longtemps
[Applaudissements]
notre pays a besoin d'une réforme de son
système de retraites elle ne sera pas
uniforme et devra prendre en compte les
carrières longues et la pénibilité
elle devra veiller au maintien dans
l'emploi des seniors
mon gouvernement
la mènera dans la concertation avec les
bas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît mes chers collègues
laisser madame la première ministre
continuer
mon gouvernement
la mènera dans la concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux
en associant les parlementaires le plus
en amont possible
elle n'est pas ficelé elle ne sera pas à
prendre ou à laisser mais elle est
indispensable
j'ajoute que je ne peux pas que nous ne
pouvons pas nous résoudre à la
pénibilité de certains métiers par
l'innovation par la technologie par
l'évolution des carrières nous pouvons
nous devons améliorer les conditions de
travail et faire en sorte que nos
compatriotes ne finissent plus leur
carrière brisée
alors oui le travail est une valeur
essentielle le travail c'est la clef de
l'émancipation c'est la création de
richesse la liberté d'entreprendre le
partage de la valeur des ressources
complémentaires pour notre modèle social
une ambition plus fort dans la
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale des entreprises nous
avons tous à y gagner
mesdames et messieurs les députés bâtir
ensemble c'est apporter des réponses
radicales à l'urgence écologique
devant les défis il n'est plus question
d'opposer les radicaux aux partisans
d'une écologie des petits par tous nous
avons conscience des enjeux et des
risques tous nous devons faire bloc se
mouiller de radicalité je le prends donc
à mon compte nous engagerons des
transformations radicales dans notre
manière de produire de nous loger de
nous déplacer de consommer mais je la
firme je ne crois pas un instant que
cette révolution climatique passe par la
décroissance au contraire
au contraire la révolution écologique
que nous voulons mener ce sont des
innovations des filières nouvelles des
emplois d'avenir c'est un modèle social
préserver car sans activité nous ne
pourrions plus le financer au cours des
cinq dernières années nous avons
accéléré la baisse des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre mais nous devons faire
plus sous l'impulsion de la france
l'europe s'est fixée l'objectif d'être
neutre en carbone en 2050 et de réduire
ses émissions de 55 % d'ici 2030 ces
objectifs nous devons les atteindre
ensemble nous gagnerons la bataille du
climat
[Applaudissements]
pour y parvenir tout mon gouvernement
est mobilisé le président de la
république m'a chargé de la
planification écologique
chaque ministre aura une feuille de
route climats et biodiversité
nous allons définir ensemble un plan
d'action un plan de bataille dès le mois
de septembre
nous lancerons une vaste concertation en
vue d'une loi d'orientation énergie
climat
filière par filière territoire par
territoire nous définirons des objectifs
de réduction d'émissions des étapes et
des moyens appropriés la transition
écologique et la sphère de tous les
dirigeants des grandes entreprises
doivent montrer l'exemple et leur
rémunération dépendra de l'atteinte des
objectifs environnementaux
nous avancerons avec les élus locaux ils
ont en charge l'aménagement du
territoire des transports l'habitat les
déchets nous avons besoin d'eux et celle
de sens même de la création d'un
ministère de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires ils
seront également source d'inspiration
d'initiative et 10 des biens sont bien
souvent dans leur territoire ils ont
montré le chemin
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
voulons être
nous serons la première grande nation
écologique à sortir des énergies
fossiles
c'est la garantie de notre souveraineté
énergétique c'est la préservation du
pouvoir d'achat ce sont des filières
industrielles nouvelles et des emplois
créés car je le dis et je le répète
notre écologie est une écologie de
progrès je laissais cette transition
peut parfois provoquer des craintes
notamment des salariés des secteurs en
mutation
madame la présidente châtelain monsieur
le président bayou nous en avons parlé
et nous y tenons comme vous
[Applaudissements]
nous ne laisserons personne sur le bord
de la route nous avons retenu les leçons
du textile et glaciers chaque transition
il ira de pair avec un accompagnement
pour la formation et la reconversion
pour sortir du carbone nous noterons
d'un mix énergétique équilibré autour
des énergies renouvelables et du
nucléaire
nous accélérons le déploiement des
énergies renouvelables nous investirons
dans le nucléaire avec la construction
de nouveaux réacteurs et des innovations
seront par un éclair du futur
la transition énergétique passe par le
nucléaire je sais que c'est une
conviction largement partagé sur ses
bancs
c'est une énergie décarbonée souveraine
et compétitive
réussir la transition énergétique
c'est pouvoir la piloter
je le disais
je le disais il ya quelques instants
l'urgence climatique impose des
décisions fortes radical nous devons
avoir la pleine maîtrise de notre
production d'électricité et de sa
performance nous devons assurer notre
souveraineté face aux conséquences de la
guerre et aux défis colossaux à venir
nous devons prendre des décisions que
sur ses bancs même d'autres ont pu
prendre avant nous dans une période de
l'histoire ou le pays devait aussi gagné
la bataille de l'énergie et de la
production
c'est pourquoi je vous confirme
aujourd'hui l'intention de l'état de
détenir 100% du capital d'edf
[Applaudissements]
cette évolution permettra à edf de
renforcer sa capacité à mener dans les
meilleurs délais des projets ambitieux
est indispensable pour notre avenir
énergétique
[Applaudissements]
réussir la transition énergétique s'est
ensuite consommer moins si notre pays
est moins dépendants du gaz russe que
nos voisins nous ne pouvons pas croire
ou faire croire que les décisions
unilatérales de la russie nous
épargnerait si la rue s'ils venaient à
couper ses exportations de gaz nous
serions tous chez nous aussi
dès maintenant nous devons envisager
tous les scénarios concrets même les
plus difficiles et partager leurs
conséquences avec tous les acteurs et
avec les français nous pouvons tenir
mais chacun devra agir
plus largement
nous devons éviter toutes les
consommations inutiles dans le domaine
du logement nous amplifierons le succès
de ma prime rénove pour rénover 700
mille logements par an
nous voulons permettre à chacun d'avoir
accès à des transports propres cela vaut
partout en ville partout pardon en ville
comme dans la ruralité
le ferroviaire est et restera la colonne
vertébrale d'une mobilité propre
nous continuerons les investissements de
ces dernières années pour les transports
du quotidien pour les petites lignes je
veux ici rendre hommage
à l'action de jean castex
infatigable voix des territoires
et qui s'est engagé personnellement pour
le ferroviaire
partout des solutions alternatives à
usage individuel de la voiture thermique
devront être construites par tous nous
devons continuer à soutenir les
mobilités propre et active
nous souhaitons permettre aux français
d'avoir accès à une voiture zéro
émission
pour y parvenir nous prolongerons les
aides à la conversion et nous mettrons
en place un système de location de
longue durée à moins de 100 euros par
mois
c'est un projet écologique c'est une
ambition industrielle car nous
construirons ces voitures électriques en
france
au delà des transports partout nous
allons décarbonée c'est vrai notamment
dans l'industrie en nous appuyant sur
les 50 milliards d'investissements de
france 2030 la moitié au moins sera
consacrée à ces enjeux cela vaut aussi
pour l'agriculture en continuant à
transformer notre modèle agricole j'y
reviendrai
protéger l'environnement s'est enfin
préserver la nature et la biodiversité
face au risque d'une sixième grande
extinction nous accentuerons notre
politique de préservation des espaces
naturels
forêts montagnes littoraux océans nous
aurons une attention toute particulière
pour nous outre-mer dont la biodiversité
est un trésor inestimable
nous devrons enfin
poursuivre notre sortie de la société du
gaspillage et du tout jetable il faut du
réemploi de la réparation du recyclage
cela crée de l'activité du pouvoir
d'achat les outils ont été mis en place
lors du précédent quinquennat il faut
maintenant pleinement s'en emparer
vous le voyez derrière les mots derrière
les engagements l'urgence nous impose
des actes rapides tout ne viendra pas de
l'état seul chacun devra y prendre sa
part c'est la condition de la réussite
mesdames et messieurs au cours de nos
échanges j'ai vu de se dégager une autre
volonté commune bâtir la république de
l'égalité des chances
nous refusons une société où la vie et
les destins sont rasées selon le
quartier où l'on est selon le lieu où
l'on vit selon la couleur de sa peau ou
la profession de ses parents
alors au coeur de l'engagement du
président de la république et de mon
gouvernement se trouve une volonté de
briser les inégalités de destins
n'accepter aucune assignation sociale ou
culture culturel de permettre à chacun
de choisir son avenir de tracer les
chemins de l'émancipation
la république de l'égalité des chances
se construit dès la naissance
l'enfance sera une priorité de ce
quinquennat dans la droite ligne du
chantier des 1000 premiers jours nous
répondrons à la première préoccupation
des parents aujourd'hui le manque de
solutions de garde pour les enfants et
notamment les enfants de moins de 3 ans
pour réussir mon gouvernement souhaite
bâtir avec les collectivités un
véritable service public de la petite
enfance il permettra d'offrir les deux
cent mille places d'accueil manquantes
nous voulons des solutions proche des
domiciles accessible financièrement nous
viendront en aide en priorité à ceux qui
en ont le plus besoin les parents qui
élèvent seules leurs enfants le plus
souvent des femmes pour eux pour elle
nous continuerons à bâtir un
accompagnement global avec les pensions
alimentaires désormais directement
versés sur les comptes en banque nous
avons franchi une étape majeure
nous continuerons et nous accorderons
une aide aux familles monoparentales
pour la garde des enfants jusqu'à 12 ans
bâtie à la république de l'égalité des
chances c'est agir en priorité pour
l'école et la jeunesse c'est un chantier
essentiel c'est là que tout se joue nous
continuerons la refondation de l'école
en gamme entamée lors du dernier
quinquennat
notre école c'est celle qui conforte les
savoirs fondamentaux
savoirs fondamentaux lire écrire compter
respecter autrui et s'empare des
nouveaux savoirs comme le codage
informatique
notre école c'est celle qui garantit
l'égalité et ne renonce jamais à
l'excellence
nous devons pousser chaque élève à se
dépasser dans notre école nous devons
aider les jeunes à déceler et faire
éclore ces talents les adultes à déceler
même s'ils ne sont pas même s'ils ne
sont pas dans le moule
former des millions de jeunes et
s'adapter aux personnalités de chacun
c'est le défi auquel font face chaque
jour les professeurs et notre école se
doit donc donc être celle qui offre aux
enseignants la reconnaissance et la
place qu'il mérite
nous enseignons sont le coeur battant de
la république et grâce à leur
mobilisation durant la crise sanitaire
ils ont permis à notre école de rester
ouverte nous devons mieux les associer à
la transformation de l'école nour
valoriseront leur salaire et
construiront avec les évolutions de leur
profession
avec nous devrons bâtir un nouveau pacte
répondre à la question des remplacements
avancé pour l'aide individualisée
adapter leur formation soutenir les
projets collectifs
mais il serait illusoire de croire que
les solutions seraient identiques
partout sur tous les territoires
l'égalité réelle s'est adapté notre
action en fonction des situations
locales et des besoins des élèves le
plan marseillan dran lancé par le
président de la république l'année
dernière a ouvert la voie
[Applaudissements]
nous donneront des marges de manoeuvre
aux établissements pour s'adapter nous
mobiliserons toute la communauté
scolaire les associations les élus car
l'émancipation de nos jeunes passe par
l'école mais aussi par le sport la
culture l'engagement l'égalité réelle
nous la construirons dans le dialogue
avec toutes les parties prenantes cette
concertation sera lancée dès septembre
notre jeunesse doit également continuer
à faire vivre les valeurs républicaines
mon gouvernement continuera à déployer
le service national universel
d'avenir de notre jeunesse enfin passe
par un enseignement supérieur et une
recherche avec les moyens de ses
ambitions
l'université française est une chance
précieuse elle forme et 10 les esprits
elle assure la transmission et le
progrès des savoirs dans tous les champs
de connaissance
l'université sera donc au coeur de
l'action de notre gouvernement nous
améliorons les conditions de vie et
d'études de nos jeunes et new rave
renforceront l'égalité d'accès et de
réussite en particulier dans le premier
cycle universitaire et simplifieront le
système de bourses étudiantes
l'avenir de notre jeunesse s'est aussi
accompagné toutes les voix de
l'émancipation
assumons d'être une grande nation
culturelle la culture sauver la culture
grandi la culture fait l'âme et le
rayonnement de notre pays rendre la
culture accessible à toutes et tous de
la jeunesse
c'est pourquoi nous proposerons
d'étendre le bass culture dès la 6è et
d'amplifier l'éducation artistique et
culturelle
soutenir la création dans l'espace
physique comme numérique prolongeons
notre action pour sauvegarder le
patrimoine c'est notre identité notre
héritage notre histoire
bâtissons une nation sportive le sport
donne sa chance à tous offrons à chaque
élève en primaire 30 minutes de sport
par jour faisons des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 un accélérateur de
l'activité physique dans notre pays
bâtir la république de l'égalité des
chances c'est offrir à toutes et tous
une santé de qualité
les français le savent ils nous le
disent nous faisons face à un manque
criant de personnel de professionnels de
santé
cette réalité nous ne pouvons ni la nier
ni l'occulter si nous avons supprimé le
numerus clausus en 2018
nous devons aussi dire les choses cette
situation durera encore plusieurs années
face à ce défi nous devons activer tous
les leviers le premier c'est la
prévention trop souvent à tort on résume
la santé aux soins la prévention ce sont
des campagnes de santé publique les
dépistages et et les bilans de santé ou
moments clés de la vie mais bien au delà
ce doit être une vision de toutes les
politiques publiques prévenir les
maladies c'est agir sur la qualité de
l'air sur l'habitat sur les conditions
de vie c'est prendre en compte les
inégalités sociales qui sont aujourd'hui
les principaux déterminants de la santé
de chacun
c'est pourquoi avec le président de la
république nous avons souhaité que le
gouvernement comprenne un ministre de la
santé et de la prévention c'est un défi
que l'état ne peut pas relever seul nous
travaillerons avec les élus et en
particulier les maires qui sont nos
partenaires privilégiés
ensuite nous devrons soutenir les
soignants le coded a mis à jour les
fragilités de notre système de soins
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît
il a aussi montré l'engagement
exceptionnel de nos soignants et je veux
leur rendre hommage
[Applaudissements]
mais les chers collègues s'il vous plaît
pas de telles manifestations dans
l'hémicycle s'il vous plaît même
ça n'a rien
[Applaudissements]
c'est d'abord grâce à nos soignants que
notre pays a tenu notre de vin et de
continuer à agir
ne ségur de la santé a permis des
revalorisations sans précédent des
rémunérations des soignants et des
moyens inédits pour notre hôpital
pourtant tout n'est pas réglé loin de là
nous avons pris des mesures d'urgence
pour cet été l'heure est maintenant aux
solutions structurantes nous devons
renforcer l'attractivité des métiers
nous devons permettre aux soignants de
passer plus de temps auprès des patients
en allégeant la charge administrative et
en renforçant la coopération entre les
professionnels de santé nous devons
investir sur l'innovation pour
moderniser notre système de soins nous
devons construire dans chaque territoire
une offre de santé adaptés je suis
convaincu que les solutions viendront
des professionnels des élus des patients
et du terrain
[Applaudissements]
dès septembre des concertations seront
lancés partout en france avec un
objectif clair lutter contre les déserts
médicaux par une meilleure coordination
entre les acteurs entre la ville et
l'hôpital entre le public et le privé
nombreux en ont parlé notamment le
président va l'eau sur ce sujet ici nous
pouvons construire des consensus
[Applaudissements]
je vais ici aussi rappelé que l'épidémie
de covin n'est pas finie et qu'elle
reprend même nettement ces derniers
jours si notre système de santé est
aujourd'hui préservée nous devons rester
vigilants et prêts à agir
bâtir la république de l'égalité des
chances c'est faire de la france un pays
où l'on vieillit bien un pays qui
favorise l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé un pays qui assure une prise en
charge de qualité à domicile ou en
maison de retraite notre première
mission donnée aux personnes âgées la
capacité de vieillir sereinement chez
elle nous y parviendrons avec le
dispositif ma prime adapte pour leur
permettre d'aménager leur logement
nous y parviendrons en améliorant la
qualité des services à domicile mais il
nous faut aussi améliorer la vie de nos
aînés en maison de retraite les
scandales récents sont révoltants nous
avons renforcé les contrôles pour qu'il
ne puisse plus survenir nous devons
maintenant inventer les établissements
de demain à la fois plus ouvert plus
humain et mieux médicalisé nous devons
construire des liens plus forts entre
établissements et domicile créé des
ehpad hors les murs pour une prise en
charge toujours plus adaptée à chaque
situation
les investissements du ségur ont été une
étape majeure pour cette transformation
mais nous devons aussi relevé le défi de
l'attractivité pour permettre le
recrutement de 50 mille infirmiers et
aides soignants d'ici 2027
lors du précédent quinquennat nous avons
créé la cinquième branche de la sécurité
sociale
nous avons posé les fondements du
financement de cette nouvelle solidarité
nationale pour le grand âge là encore
avec les départements je vous propose de
travailler ensemble et de bâtir un
service public efficace qui répondent
aux besoins des personnes âgées et des
familles au plus près des territoires
bâtir la république de l'égalité des
chances c'est aussi construire une
société inclusive
le handicap ces 12 millions de français
c'est un conjoint un parent un enfant
toutes nos familles sont concernées au
fond leur une société qui accepte qui
inclut qui respecte
[Applaudissements]
une conférence nationale du handicap se
tiendra début 2023 nous agirons pour
l'accessibilité universelle
pour l'autonomie des personnes
handicapées notamment financières par
pour la transformation des structures
médico sociales pour une rom meilleure
reconnaissance des personnels de
l'accompagnement nous devons améliorer
l'inclusion par le travail dans le
milieu ordinaire d'abord ainsi que dans
les esat ou en entreprise adaptée et je
vous annonce que mon gouvernement
réformera avec vous avec les
associations l'allocation adulte
handicapé
[Applaudissements]
il s'agira d'une réforme en profondeur
nous partirons du principe de la dea
conjugale isation
[Applaudissements]
c'est une question
c'est une question de dignité et une
avancée très attendu à
[Applaudissements]
bâtir la république de l'égalité des
chances c'est réussir la cohésion des
territoires avec les territoires avec
leurs élus nous voulons une relation
fondée sur le respect le dialogue et
l'action c'est une préoccupation
partagée nous avons nous en avons
beaucoup parlé ensemble monsieur le
président barck angeli leçon au
président chassé m je veux saluer
l'engagement et la détermination des
élus locaux je les dis les politiques
publiques doivent se construire avec eux
la crise sanitaire la montre et quand
nous travaillons main dans la main nous
pouvons tout surmonté les cinq dernières
années ont permis de commencer à réduire
les factures de notre france nous avons
créé plus de 2000 maisons france ervices
nous avons investi pour redynamiser les
centres villes et les centres bourgs et
accélérer le renouvellement urbain mon
gouvernement poursuivra la logique de
différenciation partout elles répondent
aux attentes monsieur le président
penchèrent nous n'avons évoqué ensemble
la
règle commune doit pouvoir s'adapter en
fonction des spécificités de chaque
territoire nous voulons donner plus de
poids aux élus locaux plus de visibilité
dans leurs compétences plus de cohérence
dans leurs actions le conseiller
territorial
peut-être un moyen d'y parvenir est de
construire les complémentarités
indispensable entre départements et
régions
cela passera naturellement par des
concertations approfondies que nous
lancerons l'an prochain pour mener à
bien leur mission les collectivités ont
besoin de visibilité et de stabilité
dans leurs compétences c'est l'enjeu de
l'agenda territoriale que nous devons
bâtir ensemble et à une collectivité
doit se donner une lecture commune des
défis à relever des leviers à activer
des moyens nécessaires
en corse le cycle des discussions
engagées avec les élus et les forces
vives sera relancé dans les prochains
jours il doit aboutir à des solutions
concrètes pour tous les corses et
notamment la jeunesse des solutions
concrètes pour le travail pour le
logement pour la transition écologique
pour le développement économique et la
sécurité
nous sommes prêts à ouvrir tous les
sujets y compris institutionnels allait
discuter en transparence dans un esprit
constructif et responsable mais ne
cédons pas à la facilité répondons au
cas par cas à ceux qui bloquent ou
dysfonctionne
mon gouvernement sera aussi celui de la
justice territoriale quartiers
prioritaires ou ruraux nos territoires
partage des défis communs bâti dégradé
manque de transports collectifs accès à
la santé et à l'emploi sécurité de tous
les territoires de france j'entends
cette demande commune de justice de
cohésion de considération nous allons y
répondre pour nous quartier nous
bâtirons des solutions qui change le
quotidien et redonne des opportunités
nous définirons les nouveaux contrats de
ville et répondront aux urgences avec
les habitants avec les associations avec
les élus locaux
mèneront des opérations de
renouvellement urbain est essentielle
car l'égalité cela commence par l'état
de sa rue de son rôle d'immeubles et de
son école pour la ruralité nous
continuerons à investir un nouvel agenda
rural sera mise en oeuvre nous
continuerons le déploiement de france
service pour garantir des services
publics de proximité et de qualité aux
habitants
nous lutterons contre la fracture
numérique
nous irons au bout de la couverture
mobile et très haut débit de notre
territoire nous accélérons les formation
et l'accompagnement aux usages
numériques
la cohésion des territoires ce sont
aussi des fonctionnaires présents
partout et un état qui répond vite et
bien aux demandes des français s'est
donné aux fonctionnaires les moyens de
leur action nous continuerons la
modernisation de l'état c'est offrir aux
agents les trois versants de la fonction
publique une reconnaissance et de
meilleures conditions de travail c'est
le sens notamment de la revalorisation
du point d'indicé la plus importante
depuis près de 40 ans
je vais aussi avoir un mot particulier
pour nos compatriotes d outre mer les
outre mer sont une chance inestimable
pour notre pays ce sont des terres de
jeunesse et d'espoir ce sont les places
fortes de notre souveraineté plus que
jamais nous avons besoin de nos
outre-mer
pourtant ces derniers mois vous avez dit
vos doutes vos craintes et vos colères
il y a quelques jours toutes les
collectivités d'outre-mer se sont
rassemblés pour lancer l'appel de fort
de france nous leur répondrons mon
gouvernement les accompagnera pour
soutenir leur développement économique
et créer de l'emploi pour renforcer la
présence des services publics et assurer
la sécurité pour améliorer avec les
collectivités la distribution d'eau
potable l'assainissement le traitement
des déchets pour agir sur toutes les
causes de la vie chère comme dans
l'hexagone nous devons avancer sur tous
ces sujets placez les outre-mer aux
avant postes de la transition écologique
et je demande à tous mon gouvernement la
plus grande attention pour les
territoires ultramarins
ce quinquennat serait également celui
d'une nouvelle page de notre histoire
républicaine avec la nouvelle calédonie
nous aurons à écrire l'avenir de notre
relation au terme du processus politique
définie par l'accord de nouméa de nouméa
les discussions seront engagées avec
l'ensemble des parties j'y prendrai
comme mes prédécesseurs tout ma part et
je vais ici rendre hommage à l'action
d'edouard philippe figure du sens de
l'état face aux crises chacun connaît
son engagement pour l'avenir de la
nouvelle calédonie
bâtir la république de l'égalité des
chances c'est agir pour notre sécurité
c'est une conviction qui m'anime
profondément une conviction qui s'est
rangé tout au long de mon parcours en
particulier sous l'uniforme de prêt fait
car l'insécurité c'est une inégalité
l'insécurité touche directement et
violemment ceux qui ont déjà été
fragilisés par la vie ce qui dit dans
des quartiers où des zones où certains
cherchent à imposer leur loi face à
celle de la république le combat pour la
sécurité c'est donc un combat pour
l'égalité ce combat mon gouvernement le
mènera avec fermeté j'ai confiance dans
nos forces de l'ordre et j'ai le plus
grand respect pour elle c'est pour cela
que j'ai envers elle la plus grande
exigence
et je le dis sans détour
honte à ceux qui attaquent
systématiquement nos policiers et nos
gendarmes ont pas ceux qui tentent de
dresser les français contre ceux qui les
protègent
nous voulons une gendarmerie et une
police républicaine au plus près des
français les français veulent des
réponses fortes pour leur sécurité du
quotidien nous en parlions ensemble
madame la présidente berger les cinq
dernières années ont permis de donner
des moyens exceptionnels à nos forces de
sécurité intérieure nous avons recruté
dix mille policiers et gendarmes
supplémentaires nous avons fortifier
notre sécurité civile et agit pour nos
sapeurs pompiers nous avons renforcé
notre lutte contre le terrorisme et les
moyens de notre nos services de
renseignement en prolongeant l'effort
entamé depuis les attentats de 2015 le
quinquennat qui s'ouvre doit nous
permettre d'amplifier cet effort autour
d'une vision globale et de moyens pour
notre sécurité
c'est pourquoi mon gouvernement vous
proposera une loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'intérieur les défis sont nombreux
contre l'insécurité du quotidien contre
la cyber délinquance contre les trafics
nous renforcerons encore les moyens de
notre sécurité je suis élue d'une
circonscription rurale j'étais prêt fait
d'une région largement rurale je sais ce
qu'est le sentiment d'abandon de
certains territoires et la crainte de
voir la sécurité s'éloigner il ne doit
pas y avoir de zone blanche de la
sécurité aussi nous engageons la
création de 200 nouvelles brigades de
gendarmerie
ces dernières années ont montré la
nécessité de mieux assurer l'ordre
républicain nous créerons 11 nouvelles
unités de forces mobiles mais chacun le
sait sur ses bancs et les français nous
le disent les solutions ne se trouve pas
uniquement dans des effectifs
supplémentaires
moi j'entends la colère des français
l'exaspération des forces de l'ordre
face aux multirécidivistes
la réponse c'est le refus de l'impunité
nous doublerons le temps de présence des
forces de l'ordre sur le terrain d'ici
[Applaudissements]
cela se fera grâce à nos recrutements en
allégeant les procédures en les
modernisant une profonde réforme de
l'investigation sera mise en place avec
une formation plus longue le passage
obligatoire de l'examen d'officier de
police judiciaire et la création des
assistants d' enquête la réponse c'est
aussi l'efficacité de la justice ce sont
des décisions rapides et respecter les
états généraux de la justice lancée par
le président de la république ont montré
qu'il fallait des moyens supplémentaires
et des méthodes nouvelles qu'il fallait
répondre à la crise de confiance de nos
concitoyens aux attentes fortes des
professionnels et garantir toujours
l'indépendance de la justice mon
gouvernement vous proposera une loi de
programmation pour la justice nous
voulons notamment recruté 8500
magistrats et personnels de justice
supplémentaire pour une justice plus
proche pour réduire les délais et
permettre aux juges de se concentrer sur
leurs missions fondamentales nous
agirons pour que chaque aide chaque
peine prononcée soit exécuté et pour
lutter contre la surpopulation carcérale
une quarantaine d'établissements
pénitentiaires 15000 places seront
livrés dans les prochaines années je
veux que nous ayons en lien étroit avec
les élus les associations les magistrats
et les forces de l'ordre une action
toujours plus résolu dans la lutte
contre les violences sexuelles sexistes
et les violences intrafamiliales c'est
mon combat je les portais comme préfète
je le porterai comme première ministre
pour que les victimes soit écouté
protéger accompagner pour que les
plaintes soient déposées et la justice
dit c'est une exigence absolue qui
nécessite une mobilisation absolue
enfin bâtir la république de l'égalité
des chances c'est porter nos valeurs et
les défendre avec intransigeance la
liberté l'égalité la fraternité et la
laïcité ne sont pas négociables
la laïcité c'est un pilier de notre
pacte républicain
face à elle le séparatisme et
l'islamisme sont des périls mortels ils
s'en prennent à notre unité républicaine
ils sont le terreau de la radicalisation
et du terrorisme
mon gouvernement continuera à les
combattre de toutes ses forces
l'égalité c'est refuser les
discriminations avec tout mon
gouvernement je serai une combattante
pour l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes elle est la grande cause du
quinquennat
nous agirons dans tous les domaines et
notamment pour l'égalité économique
nous lutterons avec intransigeance
contre toutes les discriminations
qu'elles concernent le genre la religion
la couleur de la peau le handicap
l'orientation sexuelle chaque
discrimination est une humiliation une
blessure une violence alors en
concertation avec tous les acteurs nous
continuerons à les prévenir et les
sanctionner
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
voudrais à présent vous parler de notre
souveraineté la souveraineté ça n'est ni
le repli sur soi ni l'exclusion au
contraire c'est notre capacité à peser
et affronter les crises
cette souveraineté est à la fois
profondément française est profondément
européenne la pandémie nous a prouvé
notre trop forte dépendance aux
industries étrangères la guerre en
ukraine nous a rappelé que nous devions
faire front pour faire entendre notre
voix les crises migratoires nous ont
montré le besoin de solidarité
européenne et la nécessité de toujours
mieux protéger nos frontières l'union
européenne nous protège et nous projette
dans l'avenir une europe plus fort c'est
une france plus fort
la présidence française du conseil
européen a permis plus de 130 accord et
autant de réponses pour le climat le
numérique l'autonomie stratégique les
droits sociaux ou l'égalité des femmes
les défis de la souveraineté nous
attendent bâtissons ensemble une france
plus forte dans une europe plus
indépendante
une france plus forte dans une europe
indépendante c'est la souveraineté
énergétique
nous ne pouvons plus dépendre du gaz et
du pétrole russes je l'évoquais plus tôt
nous gagnerons notre souveraineté grâce
au nucléaire et aux énergies
renouvelables
ou une france plus forte dans une europe
plus indépendante c'est la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique nous sommes
sur la bonne voie par les baisses
d'impôts par la réforme du marché du
travail par l'attractivité retrouvée
nous avons mis un coup d'arrêt à 40 ans
de désindustrialisation
maintenant accélérons accélérons en
continuant à attirer les entreprises et
les industries
comme annoncé par le président de la
république nous vous proposerons de
baisser encore les impôts de production
et de supprimer la cvae et la loi de
finances 2023
concrètement ce sont près de 8 milliards
qui permettront de renforcer la
compétitivité de nos entreprises aux
trois quarts des pme et des hôtels
concrètement aussi nous compenserons
cette perte de ressources auprès des
collectivités
accélérons en investissant massivement
sur les secteurs d'avenir comme
l'alimentation l'énergie nous spatiale
lait bio médicaments ou l'électronique
bâtissons les filières d'excellence
française et européenne c'est le sens
des 50 milliards d'euros
d'investissements de france 2030 pour
l'innovation pour la recherche pour la
réindustrialisation
plus largement nous reste nous
investirons dans nos sites
universitaires et nos organismes de
recherche nous continuerons à
revaloriser et à simplifier le métier de
chercheur la recherche quel qu'en soit
le domaine inspire et fait la force de
notre pays je veux rendre hommage à
l'excellence de nos universités et
laboratoires et en disant ces mots je
veux féliciter au nom du gouvernement le
mathématicien hugo duminil copains dans
l'amygdale fille fait la fierté de toute
notre recherche
accélérons en protégeant et promouvant
notre culture et notre création
accélérons aussi en tenant notre rang de
grandes nations numériques une nation
qui soutient sa french tech une nation
capable d'apprendre à ces jeunes les
bons usages capable à travers la
régulation de lutter contre le
cyber-harcèlement et la haine en ligne
une france plus forte dans une europe
plus indépendante c'est notre
souveraineté alimentaire le constat est
édifiant près de la moitié des
agriculteurs prendront leur retraite
d'ici 2030 nous devons assurer l'avenir
de la filière agricole la représentation
nationale a montré au tour de la
question des retraites agricoles
qu'elles pouvaient s'unir pour nos
agriculteurs alors bâtissons ensemble
une loi d'orientation et d'avenir pour
l'agriculture
elle permettra de faire émerger une
nouvelle génération d'agriculteurs
cela passe d'abord par une meilleure
rémunération par le soutien à la
transmission de nos exploitations à
l'entrepreneuriat c'est la poursuite de
notre soutien massif à l'adaptation de
l'agriculture au changement climatique
avec l'assurance récolte avec des moyens
de protection des exploitations c'est
l'investissement pour de nouvelles
productions les protéines végétales
notamment c'est la protection dans les
accords internationaux contre la
concurrence déloyale des pays qui ne
respectent pas nos critères sociaux et
environnementaux
c'est une politique d'alimentation qui
respecte chacun des acteurs et leur
donne une juste rémunération
beaucoup a été fait lors du premier
quinquennat
[Musique]
beaucoup a été fait lors du précédent
quinquennat nous devons continuer
mesdames et messieurs les députés une
france plus forte dans une europe plus
indépendante c'est également tenir nos
frontières au niveau européen nous
poursuivrons le travail entamé sous
présidence française pour renforcer
schengen pour des contrôles accrus aux
frontières de l'europe pour une
politique d'asile mieux coordonner au
niveau national la france restera fidèle
à sa tradition d'asile et pour que cette
politique soit juste nous devrons
poursuivre l'accélération du traitement
des demandes à ce que nous accueillons
nous devons offrir une meilleure
intégration par le travail et nous
devons dans le même temps reconduire
plus rapidement ce dont la demande
d'asile a été refusée pour y parvenir
nous allons simplifier et moderniser les
procédures
je veux le dire aussi disposer d'un
titre de séjour en france impose de
respecter ses lois nous serons
intransigeants sur ce point
en matière d'immigration irrégulière
nous continuerons notre lutte à tous les
niveaux nous créerons une force aux
frontières nous poursuivrons notre
combat contre les passeurs ils auront
ils organisent des véritables trafic
d'êtres humains doivent être poursuivis
et sanctionnés une france plus forte
dans une europe plus indépendante enfin
c'est notre souveraineté stratégique la
guerre aux portes de l'europe et le
maintien de la menace terroriste
nous le rappelle nous devons pouvoir
nous défendre nous devons pouvoir faire
entendre notre voix au levant au sahel
sur le flanc est de l'europe sur terre
dans les airs sur les mers dans le
cyberespace partout et dans tous les
milieux nous armer se bat pour notre
liberté parfois au péril de leur vie je
veux dire à nous armer le plein soutien
et la confiance du gouvernement de la
nation ici représentés je veux leur
rendre hommage et avoir une pensée pour
nos soldats tombés au combat pour les
familles endeuillées et pour tous ceux
revenus des terrains d'opération
meurtris dans leur chair tout dans leur
esprit
où
le contexte géopolitique et les
désordres du monde nous oblige nous
devons disposer d'un modèle d'armée
conques les équilibres et moderniser un
modèle d'armée cohérent et capables
d'agir le précédent quinquennat a permis
un effort sans précédent depuis la fin
de la guerre froide pour nous armer nous
avons respecté l'exécution de la loi de
programmation militaire nous avons
moderniser nos infrastructures nous
n'est un renouvellement massif de nos
équipements et lancer les grands
programmes d'avenir comme celui du
nouveau porte avions nous devons
maintenant poursuivre et amplifier cet
investissement prochainement le
président de la république annoncera les
contours d'une nouvelle loi de
programmation militaire
il donnera une vision et un cap à nos
armées
comme à notre industrie de défense en
tirant tous les enseignements de
l'engagement de nos forces et de la
coopération avec d'autres armes et nous
tiendrons notre rôle nous agirons en
cohérence avec nos ambitions européennes
et nous alliés de l'otan nous devrons
aussi fortifier la résilience de la
nation et par l'accroissement de la
réserve par des actions auprès de notre
jeunesse par le travail sur la mémoire
par l'attention portée aux anciens
combattants nous renforcerons le lien
armée nation
la france sous l'impulsion du président
de la république devra enfin tenir toute
sa place sur la scène internationale
cela veut dire plus d'efforts en matière
de solidarité internationale
une ambition accrue pour les défis
globaux comme la santé ou le changement
climatique
cela vous de venir poursuivre le
renouvellement de notre relation avec
l'afrique parle aux dialogues parlés
partenariat par le travail de mémoire
madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés
je viens de vous présenter l'ambition
que porte mon gouvernement
je voulais dit elle est le socle de
notre travail à venir
mais les moyens de l'atteindre pourront
être enrichie amender
les échanges nourris que j'ai menées
avec les groupes de cette assemblée me
le montre nous avons les moyens et la
volonté de nous retrouver autour de
valeurs aux objectifs communs
de construire ensemble de bâtir
collet
[Musique]
nous avons les moyens et la volonté de
nous retrouver autour de valeurs et
d'objectifs communs de construire
ensemble et de porter des majorités
d'idées
l'heure n'est pas à nous conter mais à
nous parler
[Applaudissements]
la confiance ne se décrète pas a priori
elles se font jour à texte a pretext
projet après projet car nous
travaillerons en bonne foi et en bonne
intelligence
comme nous le demandent les français
devant chaque défi nous devrons nous
poser la question
voulons-nous bloquer ou voulons-nous
construire
7 en fonction de cela que les français
nous jugeront
les enjeux devant nous sont immenses
mais je suis confiante et déterminée
notre pays est celui de tous les
possibles
celui qui à surmonter les crises une à
une avec force et solidarité celui qui
refuse la fatalité
celui où la promesse républicaine peut
et doit avoir un sens et une réalité
cette conviction je la tiens de mon
histoire car si je suis ici devant vous
premier ministre de la france je le dois
à la république
c'est elle
c'est elle qui m'a tendu la main en me
faisant pupille de la nation alors que
j'étais cet enfant dont le père n'était
jamais vraiment revenu des camps
c'est elle qui m'a montré que le travail
peut déjouer les destin tracé et qui m'a
donné un métier
c'est elle qui me guide et me pousse
dans mon engagement est là qui je veux
rendre un peu de ce qu'elle m'a donné
c'est la république qui a ouvert la voie
à tant de femmes avant moi je pense à
irène joliot curie suzanne lacore et
cécile cécile breivik première femme
membre d'un gouvernement en 1936 sous le
front populaire
je pense aux 33 première femme à faire
leur entrée dans cet hémicycle au
lendemain de la libération
je pense à simone veil dont la force et
le courage m'inspire pas ce que tu dis
je pense à idées de cresson première
femme à accéder aux fonctions de premier
ministre
et je sais dans cette assemblée présidée
pour la première fois par une femme
et comme chaque femme sur ses bancs ce
que je dois à toutes celles qui ont
ouvert le chemin avant nous je crois à
la force de l'exemple et le combat
continuera jusqu'à ce que l'égalité ne
pose plus de questions
j'ai partagé avec vous un peu de mon
histoire mais l'histoire dans la
république c'est celle de toutes les
françaises et de tous les français
la france notre france c'est celle des
enseignants qui donnent des visages et
des noms à la transmission et à
l'émancipation
la france notre france c'est celle des
soignants qui ne comptent pas leurs
heures et n'ont reculé devant aucun
effort pendant plus de deux années de
pandémie
celle des travailleurs de la deuxième
ligne qui ont assuré la continuité de
notre économie celle des commerçants qui
ont été exemplaires et ont tenu
la france notre france c'est celle de
cette jeunesse qui nous met devant nos
responsabilités
s'engage pour le climat prête à se
battre pour notre destin commun
la france notre france c'est celle des
créateurs des entrepreneurs des
travailleurs des fonctionnaires des
artisans des agriculteurs
c'est celle qui vient en aide à ceux qui
en ont besoin qui ne laisse personne sur
le côté étant toujours la main c'est
celle de la seule solidarité de
l'engagement et de la volonté
c'est aussi celle des craintes que nous
devons écouter des peurs auxquelles nous
devons répondre et aussi parfois des
colères que nous devons apaiser
cette france c'est la nôtre alors soyons
à sa hauteur à la hauteur des françaises
et des français
une nouvelle page de notre histoire
politique s'ouvre nous allons l'écrire
ensemble alors devant vous je m'engage à
partager les enjeux et les contraindre à
vous faire part de nos feuilles de route
et des différentes voies que nous
pourrions en traités je m'engage à ne
jamais rompre le fil du dialogue avec
les groupes parlementaires avec les
forces vives avec les françaises et les
français je m'engage à bâtir des
compromis ambitieux sans compromission
sur les valeurs des solutions concrètes
des majorités de projets et d'idées les
français ont sonné l'heure de la
responsabilité
nous serons au rendez vous nous avons
toutes et tous une part à prendre nous
avons tout pour réussir
bâtir ensemble nous y parviendrons je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]